as leader the Bosnian Serb army Ratko
Mladic was the most feared commander of
the brutal war in the Balkans his was
the iron fist that symbolized the Serbs
ethnic cleansing campaign his physical
presence at the scene of the worst
atrocity of the conflict saw him facing
charges of crimes against humanity it
was general manager help plan and
execute the bloody siege of Sarajevo for
months targeting helpless civilians
trapped in the city beneath the Bosnian
Serb gun positions in the mountains
adored by his troops he encouraged some
of the worst excesses of the war but it
is the events of the summer of 1995 and
the shrubbery needs sir Enclave that
general knowledge will forever be held
responsible after five days of heavy
shelling ladach is filmed entering the
town to organize the buses that would
take the women and children away don't
be afraid he says no one will harm you
those left behind 7,500 men and boys
were murdered over the next few days it
was the single most terrible crime of
the Bosnian war and left
Ratko Mladic a wanted criminal indicted
by the United Nations war crimes
tribunal in The Hague he faces charges
of genocide crimes against humanity and
violations of laws of war in all Larrick
shares 16 counts of genocide with
Radovan Karadzic the former Bosnian Serb
leader in his ideological soulmate